à quelques jours près si l'on excepte la
parenthèse de l'été du début de
l'automne 2020 ça va faire un an que nos
établissements culturels ont baissé le
rideau
au delà de ses conséquences économiques
la fermeture des salles de spectacle un
impact important sur la vie sociale de
tous les français
elle met également en danger les
artistes et notre modèle culturel
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
accueillons ce matin plusieurs
intervenants qui représente les salles
de spectacles de musique et théâtre
privé public ou subventionnées suite à
un contre temps malheureusement la
fédération nationale des cinémas
français ne pourra pas se joindre à nous
ce matin je voudrais donc tout ce vous
remercier les uns et les autres d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation au delà du
voeu que nous formulons tous de voir les
lieux de culture rouvrir le plus vite
possible
nous comptons sur vous pour nous faire
part de la situation de vos
établissements à la fois sur un plan
économique et sur les éventuelles
mesures sanitaires qui permettrait de
reprendre l'activité
je remercie également particulièrement
le professeur antoine flahault de venir
nous éclairer sur ce point je vous
propose donc de vous céder la parole
sans attendre pour un bref propos
liminaire auquel au cours duquel vous
pourrez partager avec nous votre
appréciation également sur l'aide
apportée par l'état et les collectivités
territoriales
depuis le début de la crise et nous
indiquer si vous identifier des
adaptations législatives ou
réglementaires qui permettrait de
surmonter certaines difficultés que vous
pourriez rencontrer
donc je vais vous céder la parole pour
un exposé liminaire bref de cinq minutes
environ à une personne par les
organisations représentées les autres
évidemment pourront intervenir ensuite
dans le débat ensuite je donnerai la
parole à nos deux rapporteurs roger
karoutchi et jean michel arnaud pour
qu'il puisse vous interroger et ensuite
l'ensemble de mes collègues sénateurs ne
manquera pas de vous poser des questions
je vous propose donc de commencer
peut-être par le syndicat national du
spectacle musical et de variété le
prodiss donc qui s'exprime au nom du
saika madame céline alors vous appuyez
voilà surtout il faut mettre le son que
tout le monde nous entendent bien
puisque beaucoup de participants sont
visioconférence avec nous
bonjour bien merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur rapporteur
et mesdames et messieurs et cher cher
collègue du spectacle vivant
merci beaucoup de nous donner l'occasion
de s'exprimer dans le cadre de votre
mission
donc effectivement nous allons ici nous
exprimer pour le spectacle vivant privé
pour les salles de spectacle présente en
france les festivals les producteurs de
spectacles présent sur toute la france
et comme vous l'avez dit à l'arrêt
depuis un an maintenant intégralement à
l'arrêt parce que pour notre secteur
d'activité privée il n'ya eu vraiment
quasiment aucune aucune reprise
alors en effet la situation est
particulièrement difficile après cette
année parce que nous n'avons pas de
perspective réelle deux reprises avant
cette crise nous pouvions dire que notre
secteur participé très activement à la
vitalité économique de nos territoires
nos études de l'époque on a l'impression
de parler d'un temps d'un temps qui est
très très loin démontré que pour 1 euros
générés par le coeur de nos industries
un euro supplémentaire été créé parmi
les prestataires est au coeur de au sein
de l'économie touristique dans les
territoires avant cette crise était
également 30 millions de spectateurs
annuels et près de 5 milliards d'euros
de retombées économiques directes et
indirectes par an que produisait notre
notre secteur d'activité alors avec
cette crise d'importantes pertes
nous avions l'année dernière lancer une
étude avec le cabinet iwai pour estimer
les pertes
nous avions posé l'hypothèse d'un
scénario noir avec absence de reprise
nous pensions nous tromper et finalement
malheureusement la réalité nous a
rattrapé puisqu'il n'y a eu aucune
reprise
la perte de chiffre
à faire pour notre secteur en 2020 est
donc estimée à 84 % du chiffre
d'affaires habituel et s'élève ainsi à 2
3 milliards d'euros de pertes la perte
de nos entreprises très importante et
l'étude que nous avons menées avec des
entretiens auprès des entreprises
révéler qu'il faudrait attendre près de
sept ans soit jusqu'en 2028 pour
récupérer les pertes nettes subis par
les entreprises du secteur est
effectivement dernières informations
chiffrées importante nous avions évalué
que près d'une entreprise sur deux était
menacé à terme de faillite alors
effectivement vous allez me dire pour le
moment nous ne parlons pas de faillite
et c'est normal puisque nous avons la
chance de bénéficier d'un certain nombre
de dispositifs transversaux extrêmement
important dont nous allons parler mais
néanmoins aujourd'hui un an après nous
nous commençons vraiment à nous poser la
question de la reprise parce que nous
continuons à vis dans une incertitude
très forte incertitude qui n'est
absolument plus tenable pour un secteur
un secteur d'autant plus privé pour
plusieurs raisons la date d'arrêt nos
activités vous l'avez dit cela fait un
an et nous avons été les premiers coups
de touché puisqu'il s'agissait de
d'interdire les rassemblements de plus
de cinq mille personnes
donc ce sont une grande partie de nos
activités et peu de secteurs sont dans
la même situation que nous avec un an
sans un ch'ti vite et la composition
notre secteur également qui rend la
situation difficile puisque c'est plus
de 90% de tpe pme
le modèle économique qui nous fragilise
puisqu'il repose exclusivement sur de la
billetterie de spectacles
depuis un an nous ne vendons plus de
billets de spectacles il n'y a donc plus
de recettes et enfin une incertitude
quant à la reprise en raison du mode de
fonctionnement et de la préparation même
des événements qu'ils rendent des délais
incompressibles
nous ne cessons d'expliquer à nos
interlocuteurs que nous ne reprendrons
pas d'un claquement de doigts dans le
secteur du spectacle vivant il faut du
temps il faut y a du temps long de
préparation de remise en route des
spectacles des équipes artistiques et
techniques des entreprises qui sont à
l'arrêt mais également de remettre en
vente des billets de spectacle donc il
faut au minimum entre trois et quatre
mois pour relancer un spectacle de
petite capacité et jusqu'à 24 mois pour
les très grandes tournées qui irriguent
ensemble de la france ce manque de
visibilité de visibilité et
d'anticipation et illustré avec le cas
récent des festivals puisque madame la
ministre a annoncé le 18 février qu'il y
aurait des rassemblements cet été qu'il
y aurait des rassemblements jusqu'à 5000
personnes en asie' distancié à priori
sans barney restauration mais il
faudrait encore discuté du protocole
sanitaire et se revoir chaque mois pour
adapter la situation ce n'est pas une
vraie date de reprise puisque nous
n'avons justement pas de date
les festivals sont repartis avec cette
info la seule certitude qui l'on sait
pas de rassemblement de boue pas plus de
mais on ne sait rien d'autre et on ne
sait surtout pas à partir de quelle date
ces rassemblements peuvent se tenir et
nous avons des festivals qui commence
nous dès le mois de mai notamment avec
le printemps de bourges donc évolutive
cette situation effectivement la
ministre nous a dit perdez pas espoir
puisque nous allons nous revoir tous les
mois mais dans notre secteur nous
n'envisageons pas des événements mois le
mois il nous faut de l'anticipation et
de la visibilité
c'est pour cela que depuis début janvier
nous demandons à madame la ministre au
gouvernement à calendrier de reprise
mais un calendrier de reprise avec des
dates lissante deux reprises nous avons
besoin de perspectives nous donc on a
travaillé sur des phasages mais
déphasage qui était dépourvu de critères
pour passer d'un face d'une phase une à
une phase 2 est dépourvue de toute date
donc impossible pour des entreprises de
se projeter et de recommencer à
programmer et à investir alors à côté de
tout cela effectivement nous avons pu
bénéficier d'un accompagnement de l'état
important au même titre que les autres
entreprises en france puisqu'il y a eu
des dispositifs transversaux très fort
le dispositif d'activité partielle
effectivement très important et nous
faisons partie des secteurs dérogatoire
jusqu'à présent nous avons de la
visibilité jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
si la situation devait malheureusement
se poursuivent nous espérons être
accompagné au delà du 30 juin
il y a aussi désormais un fonds de
solidarité renforcée
il a fallu aussi se bagarrer pour
pouvoir voir nos entreprises continuer à
bénéficier de ce fonds solidarité
renforcée et la question aussi des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
patronales
à côté de ces dispositifs transversaux
nous avons aussi un dispositif
sectorielle au sein du centre national
de la musique qui a été pensé à un
moment où tout le monde croyait qu'il y
aura une reprise rapide en 2021
ce n'est pas le cas nous comprenons tous
désormais il faudra donc certainement
s'interroger sur la prolongation le
renforcement des dispositifs sectoriels
au sein du centre national de la musique
qui doit être l'outil d'accompagnement
de la sauvegarde des entreprises et nous
l'espérons également un moment donné
l'accompagnement à la relance ces
entreprises car justement sur la relance
nous avons un crédit d'impôt spectacle
vivant dans le secteur qui accompagne
l'investissement des producteurs de
spectacle et nous avons souhaité l'année
dernière bonifier ce crédit d'impôt pour
qu'il soit l'outil de la relance au
moment où nous pourrions reprendre
je sais que le sénat a été fortement au
soutien et je regarde sylvie qui est qui
est à nos côtés depuis toujours sur ce
dossier malheureusement nous n'avons pas
pu obtenir une bonification de ce
dispositif que pourtant nous proposions
de façon provisoire pour accompagner la
reprise
et je le répète devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment l'outil indispensable à
la relance
elle n'est pas là mais elle se prépare
et au moment il faudra reprendre avec
des entreprises qui ont auront une
trésorerie fortement fragilisé nous
aurons besoin d'un outil fiscal à nos
côtés pour réinvestir dans la production
de spectacles et enfin et j'en termine
la situation est difficile nous n'avons
pas de perspective nous comprenons
effectivement qu'il y à quelque chose
qui est difficile à envisager pour les
pouvoirs publics c'est de travailler sur
ce qu'ils appellent les jauges de boue
les concerts en jauge de boue c'est à
dire les festivals mais aussi les
concerts en mai en salles fermées qui
alimente beaucoup de non lieu en france
et pour pouvoir participer à la
discussion sur la reprise de ses
joueuses de boue qu'ils appellent comme
un cas le plus complexe puisque les gens
ne peuvent pas être distancié peuvent
être masquées mais pas distancié dans ce
cadre là nous avons porté un projet
d'expérimentation scientifique à paris
georges debout dans le cadre d'une salle
importante l'accord arena la mairie de
paris nous a soutenu très tôt dans ce
dans ce projet nous travaillons
actuellement avec l'ap-hp qui est sur le
protocole sanitaire
nous avons bien évidemment intégré dans
les discussions le ministère de la
culture et de la santé pour que ce
projet puisse avoir lieu en avril à
paris et nous permettre d'avancer de
faire un pas et de proposer
effectivement cette expérimentation pour
nous aider à organiser la reprise des
jauges de boue les jauges assises je
pense auront moins de difficultés à
reprendre quand le d'autorisation seront
possibles nous souhaitons également
impérativement aujourd'hui aborder la
question des concerts et des festivals
anges aux deux bouts merci beaucoup
alors merci beaucoup à vous on va je
vais donner la parole au syndicat
national du théâtre privé je pensais à
la gentille homme que je vois à l'écran
oui cela voilà vous avez la parure le
power pareil pour cinq minutes environ
merci très bien monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs je
vous prie tout d'abord de bien vouloir
excuser président du cndp bertrand ta
main qui n'a pu se libérer pour cette
audition et qui m'a demandé de le
représenter
le syndicat national du théâtre privé et
donc l'une des organisations patronales
du secteur du spectacle vivant privé il
retrouvait entreprise de création
production diffusion de spectacles de
théâtre intervenants à l'échelle
nationale dtn producteurs des
producteurs tourneurs et des salles de
spectacles de toutes tailles et
programmation diversifiée qui constitue
le relai essentiel entre les auteurs les
artistes et le public
nous adhérons assume le risque de la
création
ils représentent 85 % de la
fréquentation théâtrale
soit plus de 3 millions de spectateurs
et 50% des spectacles d'initiative
privée en régions soit près d'un million
sur le territoire en année normale
le chiffre d'affaires des adhérents de
notre syndicat est de l'ordre de 250
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
soit très majoritairement constitué de
la billetterie sur les spectacles de
théâtre mais aussi de façon plus
marginale par des spectacles d'humour
musicaux des locations ça pour
événements et quelques capta stif nos
adhérents emploie près de 6000 salariés
dont 1500 emplois permanents et les 4500
artistes et techniciens internet ans que
nous employons ont pour caractéristique
d'être salarié sur deux très longues
périodes soit avec une moyenne de 80
dates qui est quelque chose de très
significatif pour le spectacle vivant
quand on connaît la durée des des
contrats qui sont très courts les effets
du conte premier confinement pour notre
secteur alors depuis mi mars
lorsque l'activité a été stoppé net nous
entreprise était dans une situation
économique était déjà prêt stade
déstabiliser contenu d'une fin d'année
2010 9 compliqué en raison de la forte
mobilisation sur le contre le projet de
réforme des retraites et la paralysie
des transports parisiens notamment la
mise en place du premier volet du fonds
de soutien dans la gestion a été confiée
à l'atp n'a dans un premier temps qu'on
pensait que 10 semaines d'inactivité
soutenu uniquement une partie des
charges fixes des entreprises
les entreprises ont bien sûr eu recours
à l'activité partielle que six
thématiques assez guaino pour la magie
alors partie de leurs salariés
permanents mais également pour les
intermittents avec un reste à charge
cependant important pour ceux ci
notamment en raison de la charge liée
aux congés spectacle lorsqu'il a été
possible de rouvrir en juin 2020 seuls
quelques théâtres ont été en mesure de
faire en raison des contraintes
sanitaires mais aussi hot d'être en
capacité de relancer une programmation
locale par une paire prononcé une
programmation ça ne se fait pas du jour
au lendemain on peut chiffrer l'impact
du premier confinement en termes de
perte de chiffre d'affaires de lune mars
à fin mai à près de 60 millions d'euros
pour notre secteur
notre la reprise partielle que nous
avons connu en septembre 2009 heure
alors les théâtres privés lorsque ça a
été possible on relance
leurs activités avec cette reprise se
soit fait dans des conditions de jauge
dégradé et dans le respect des
protocoles sanitaires strictes qui ont
généré des surcoûts nettoyage renforcée
mise à disposition j'avais droit
alcoolique et c est la compensation jeu
mis en place par le fonds de
compensation billetterie ce dont la
gestion a également été confiée à la stp
l'a été dans des conditions qu'on va
moins généreuses que celles du fonds de
compensation musique variété géré par le
tnm
mais surtout ce dispositif a rapidement
trouvé ses limites avec l'instauration
du couvre-feu à 21h en octobre qui a
condamné les multis programmation
pourtant essentiel à l'économie des
petites salles et randy aussi impossible
pour tous les théâtres de programmer des
spectacles pour plus de quatre fois par
semaine contre une moyenne de 6 voire 7
en temps normal nécessaire à
l'amortissement des coûts de création
des spectacles répétition grosse que sur
des corps et des cités commercialisation
etc
le deuxième confinement décidé fin
octobre elle ni un nouveau coup d'arrêt
à l'activité théâtrale après
négociations avec le ministère de la
culture un nouveau volet de d'un fonds
de soutien sectoriel a pu être mis en
place toujours avec une gestion confiait
la stp pour se tenir une partie des
charges fixes des entreprises du secteur
hors masse salariale et cette fois pour
16 semaines
cependant il a noté que quasiment toutes
les tournées les dates en région etc
annulés depuis marc 2020 pour autant les
producteurs tourneurs ont été dé
seulement à concurrence de 15 % des
concessions de leurs spectacles annulés
et non reportés via le fonds de
compensation
ce qui au regard de leurs modèles
économiques et des frais de création
engagé les places aujourd'hui dans des
situations financières de très très
grande fragilité
de plus la plupart des théâtres de
région qui accueillaient leurs
spectacles reporte encore aujourd'hui au
mieux au dernier trimestre 2001 21 foot
programmation lorsque ce n'était pas
déjà on a en 2022 voire au delà
je voudrais m'arrêter un petit instant
sur un voilà une période que nous avons
vécu un peu comme une douche de décembre
car contrairement aux espoirs qui
avaient pu naître de l'interprétation
des propos de la mise d'une possible
ouverture des théâtres en décembre les
salles de théâtre ont dû rester fermée
pendant la période de l'année qui
représente en temps normal la pus forte
période de leur activité
le cercle secteur regrette très vivement
véritable concertation avec les
professionnels les salles de spectacles
sentiment d'avoir été sacrifié alors
qu'elles ne sont pas des lieux à risque
ce camp encore très récemment démontré
une étude allemande ce sentiment d'un
secteur culturel sacrifier pourtant
fondamental si l'on ne peut pas le cas
lié le qualifié d'essentiel perdure même
si le soutien financier de l'état a été
maintenue et renforcée via les aides
générales et sectorielles
alors notre secteur il espère
aujourd'hui une reprise prochaine
mais avant de préparer la réouverture
des établissements de spectacles les
entreprises qu'elles aient poite des
lieux où qu'elle est une activité
d'entrepreneur de spectacles doivent
reprendre l'activité bien en amont du
déconfinement et de la date présumée de
rupture des spectacles bonne reprise sur
la durée pour notre secteur il est
nécessaire de connaître une échéance de
réouverture possible a minima 3 à 5
semaines pour relancer des
programmations et la commercialisation
de fait les mesures sanitaires prises à
l'automne 2009 un couvre-feu 17 octobre
confinement 30 octobre ont mis à l'arrêt
la filière théâtrale et ont créé un même
un effet de ciseaux important entre les
dépenses engagées pour laurent relancer
l'activité et l'absence de recettes
en effet les entreprises du spectacle
alors qu'elle avait engagé des coûts
fixes en coûts variables à la reprise et
spectacles et des productions n'ont pas
pu amortir est rentabilisé par des
recettes de billetterie et de ce fait
certains acteurs estiment que leur perte
sur cette période sont deux fois plus
élevés que s'il n'avait pas repris leur
activité
cet effet de ciseaux et accentué par la
fermeture des salles de spectacles dans
le dernier trimestre de l'année 2020 qui
représente environ un tiers du chiffre
d'affaires du secteur en raison de la
saisonnalité de notre activité
le stop and go et donc dramatique pour
les entreprises de théâtre alors
s'agissant des perspectives de reprise
après plus d'un an de crise à l'inter la
quasi totalité des entreprises de notre
secteur nord pga une trésorerie négative
nos entreprises ne disposant d'aucun
matelas trésorerie pour assurer leurs
besoins de trésorerie d'exploitation et
encore moins pour financer la reprise
d'activité elles ne pourront pas non
plus rembourser leur p g audi leurs
emprunts en cours
le crédit d'impôt théâtre n'est pas
encore complètement opérationnel
par ailleurs pour le théâtre privé ne
peut être envisageable de reprendre avec
le maintien des mesures de couvre-feu à
18h ou avant
nous sommes d'une activité de soin russe
dans un premier temps si une reprise des
possibles avec un forfait à 21h il
faudrait qu'elle soit envisagée avec un
principe d'horodatage laissant la
possibilité aux spectateurs de rentrer
chez eux avec une tolérance sur la
présentation de leur billet de spectacle
enfin nous estimons des mesures
financières d'accompagnement de la prise
doit aider également perdurer être
développés pour sauver les entreprises
du théâtre il est avec le maintien de
l'activité partielle avec compensation
financière de sang pour sang versé par
l'état
au delà du 31 juin et jusqu'à la fin de
l'année maintien du soutien du fonds de
solidarité complémentaire aux aides
sectorielles maintien du fonds de
compensation billetterie durant toute la
période où nous devrons reprendre avec
les jauge réduite et alignement des
conditions du théâtre sur les conditions
de secteur musical dotation d'un conte
sauvegarde sectorielle d'un montant
permettant de sauver 100 % des
entreprises et dont la gestion serait
confiée à l'est et pébereau théâtre idée
enfin nous insistons aussi sur la
nécessité de mettre en place des aides à
l'emploi pour les artistes afin de
relancer l'activité et les distributions
nombreuses il serait dramatique de voir
reprendre avec des conditions
financières très dégradées qui fera que
nous n'ayons que des seuls en scène ce
un ou deux artistes sur le plateau ce
serait vraiment dramatique on a aussi
besoin relancer l'emploi pour le secteur
et ces mesures devront être activé et
dotée en fonction de l'évolution de la
pandémie et bien évidemment quoi qu'il
en coûte que pour reprendre le propos du
président de la république
j'en ai terminé sur sur ma présentation
du théâtre il est mais si vous le
permettez je vais vous passer un autre
message qui est un message du syndicat
camus que qui représentent lé cabaret
music-hall ans avec qui nous avons créé
une fédération scène qui nous regroupe
mesdames messieurs brièvement s'il vous
plaît permet de poursuivre oui oui mais
brièvement qu'on puisse poursuivre les
présentateurs sera très bref merci une
mesdames messieurs nouvelle fois ne
pouvons que constater que les cabarets
sont les oubliés du spectacle vivant
en effet informé de cette réunion
organisée par la mission d'information
sénatoriale avec pour objet les effets
du confinement
nous avons
être invité à celle ci en réponse à
notre demande nous a été indiqué que
cette réunion sera consacrée aux salles
de théâtre et de cinéma spécifiquement
au nom du spectacle vivant en général
or aujourd'hui nous constatons que son
invité le smtp le produit suzette sv
contrairement à leurs réponses qui nous
a été faite c'est bien le spectateur en
général qui est présent pour la partie
des organisations professionnelles qui
représentent des salles de spectacles
pourquoi alors que nous représentons les
cabarets qui tous exploitent les salles
de spectacle certes un peu plus de 1000
places ne pouvons nous pas nous exprimer
devant vous élu de la nation
pourquoi notre syndicat qui est le seul
organisme qui représente les cabarets
n'est-il pas digne d'être reçus et
écoutés pourquoi cette exclusion
notre secteur est constitué de plus de
200 cas paraît environ 170 sont en
région et 85 sont adhérents du camion
nous avons une grande particularité il
est possible de consommer de rang
spectacle il en est ainsi depuis
l'origine dès qu'apparaît nos adhérents
les plus importants en quoi chacun
plusieurs centaines de salariés et sont
mondialement connus d'autres plus petits
gabarits en région sont souvent les
seuls lieux le seul lieu culturel dans
un rayon de 60 km et cabaret eric ainsi
l'ensemble du territoire et produisent
merdier spectacle parfois avec peu de
moyens surtout dans chaque cabaret on
retrouve des femmes et des hommes
passionnés par leur métier par le
cabaret cherchons 4 en permanence à
donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes pour
enchanté leur public jeune ou moins
jeune
ces hommes et ces femmes dans leur
métier dans leur entreprise sont soumis
aujourd'hui au même problème roumanie
angoisse que tous ceux ou de celles et
ceux qui sont représentés aujourd'hui
aussi comme nous sommes terriblement
optimiste nous restons à votre
disposition pour vous présenter la
situation de notre secteur des cabarets
dit je vous remercie pour votre écoute
et bien évidemment je suis ensuite part
à votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions sur le cas alors je vous
remercie pour votre présentation on
voudrait juste profiter si l'on puis
dire
l'occasion que vous me donnez à la
lecture de ce communiqué en quelque
sorte que nous débutons nos travaux sur
cette question de la culture et des
effets du confinement et des
restrictions d'activités et que nos
travaux sur cette seule question vont
durer durant tout le mois de mars que
c'est la première table ronde il y en
aura une autre
les rapporteurs procéderont en tant que
nécessaire
à des auditions complémentaires et les
contributions écrites sont sollicités et
bienvenue donc tous les acteurs seront
entendus on ne pouvait pas entendre
aujourd'hui vous le comprenez bien tous
les acteurs et je joue déjà le rôle
difficile de vous contraindre dans votre
temps de parole donc imaginez si nous
avions mis tous les acteurs autour de la
table aujourd'hui vous auriez eu à peu
près 15 secondes pour vous exprimer
donc rassurer l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde culturel
nous écouterons tout ce que nous devons
écouter tous ceux qui ont des choses à
nous dire sur cette question parce que
nous avons la volonté de trouver des
solutions et de faire des propositions
au plus vite dans les délais qui seront
possibles et pour cela d'associer
l'ensemble des interlocuteurs
je vais maintenant passer la parole dans
quelle union syndicale des ampleurs
public du spectacle vivant donc vous
êtes 3 monsieur l'aube et monsieur
lachenal et je vois monsieur morin aussi
qui nous fait la présentation
préliminaire
j'aime bien la faire en tant que
président de cette résidence weecast
bien s'accompagner de crédits à
l'équipement et bruno lobée qui pourront
y apporter des précisions on va essayer
effectivement d'être bref de ne pas
rouvrir ce qui a été dit qu'il y avait
des traits généraux que nous partageons
mais plutôt de revenir sur nos
spécificités donc union syndicale des
employeurs publics du spectacle vivant
est une fédération qui rassemble les
organisations professionnelles des
secteurs subventionnés du spectacle
vivant à travers les cases organisation
les forces musicales profedim smsp le
syndeac et les 900 adhérents qui la
composent
nous sommes caractérisée par une gestion
désintéressée aide aux entreprises et
par les missions de service public et
d'intérêt général que nous avons publiée
au corps de manière très fort le
défendons les valeurs communes de
démocratisation de la culture de liberté
de création et programmation d'exigence
artistique d'équité territoriale est une
garantie par un renforcement de la
décentralisation culturelle nous 900
entreprises que nous représentons ce
sont les centres dramatiques nationaux
les centres chorégraphiques nationaux
les centre de développement
chorégraphique centres nationaux
création musicale et celle nationale des
scènes conventionnées les orchestres
permanent les opéras les pièces de
les compagnies les festivals les
ensembles musicaux indépendante
si l'entreprise relève tout du champ de
la convention collective des départs de
national des entreprises artistiques et
culturelles
cette branche a réuni prête plus de cent
mille salariés pour une masse salariale
de plus de 800 millions d'euros et notre
fédération représente environ 70% de 7,7
de cette branche
nous avons pu mesurer les impacts du
premier confinement au printemps dernier
sur nos 900 adhérents
il faut se souvenir que c'est près de 19
mille représentations qui ont été
annulés et 180 mille heures de
répétition de résidence d'activités
annexes également la perte de recettes
de nos 100 entreprises se situent sur
cette période à près de 90 millions
d'euros dont près de la moitié concerne
les recettes billetterie
voilà nos secteurs est à l'arrêt vous
l'avez entendu on nous a progressivement
donné des libertés pour continuer à
répéter à travailler mais notre secteur
ne peut se considérer qu'à l'arrêt dans
la création n'existe que dans la
rencontre du public et toutes ces
mécanismes via les dires de travail en
ce moment et ce sont l'ensemble de
perfusion qui permettent effectivement à
certains seulement d'entre nous de
continuer une activité artistique mais
plonge l'ensemble du secteur dans le
plus grand désarroi depuis la rentrée
nos secteurs a pu montrer dans le lien
avec le public l'émancipation
individuelle de la rencontre avec la
création qu'il représente est important
que nos secteurs accusent sans cesse se
réinventer se renouveler et s'adapter
pour se conformer à aux divers
restrictions qui étaient les nôtres
vous aviez nous avons mis en place des
études scientifiques des protocoles
précis à la fois d'accueil du public et
à la fois de travail des artistes et des
équipes qui sont maintenant en tout cas
qu'ils montrent leur solidité et leur
habilité
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt nous attendons
évidemment une date de travail de
revoyure qui nous était promise une
certaine manière même par le président
de la république quand il a annoncé le
plan de reprise d'activité progressive
un an au mois de décembre il a même fixé
une dernière un dernier échéancier au
moins deux pour la fin du mois de
janvier qui n'a pas qu'il n'a pas été
tenue voilà le plan de reprise
résilience avec lequel nous travaillons
avec le ministère de la culture en
plusieurs étapes et sur la table nous
attendons à ce qu'ils puissent être
maintenant déclenché il nous faut
effectivement une anticipation pour qu
on puisse y travailler une date pour que
nous puissions en parler ou en tout cas
un état claire de la situation sanitaire
à partir de laquelle on pourra des
flottes déclenchée sur le plan a c'est
de l'étape 0 à l'état une à l'étape de l
état de droit
de nombreuses aides ont été mobilisés
pour accompagner nos secteurs nous en
sommes conscients cld sont diverses
elles sont de nature générale
sectorielle
il faut absolument faire encore le
diagnostic comment celles-ci ont pu être
mobilisés et et être au service de notre
secteur il ya une grande disparité de
régime juridique de nos entreprises qui
font qu'elles ne sont pas toutes logées
à la même enseigne
par rapport aux aides qu'elle puisse
recevoir et les bilans sur les
structures soient extrêmement
constrastée nous sommes également
extrêmement inquiets sur le maintien des
régimes sociaux qui sont aussi un outil
de gestion d'un autre branche et de
maintien de la cohésion sociale a pour
tous ceux qui vivent et travaillent de
leur métier dans nos maisons et à ce
titre tous les mécanismes
d'accompagnement sociaux des techniciens
et des artistes nous inquiètent bien
entendu dans la dans le temps puisque
cette crise s'installe maintenant de
manière durable
voilà le jeu doit quand même finir ce
propos liminaire très bref par vous
témoigner de la grande détresse dans
lequel se sait ce pardon se trouve à la
fois toutes les équipes qui font vivre
nos équipements mais aussi toutes les
équipes de création de ses équipes
techniques depuis un an d'interruption
avec aucune perspective avec un silence
radio depuis quelques mois qui se fait
de plus en plus lourd 7
cette détresse se retrouve bien entendu
sur des climats psychosociaux qui sont
maintenant risques et nous n'avons à
nous défendons le lien avec le public
l'émancipation personnel est importante
pour ceux qui travaillent aussi je passe
la parole à frédérique et bruno s'il
souhaite bien entendu précisé et et
augmenter mes propos merci oui bonjour
juste
pour eux précise et en effet le propos
de loïc il est vraiment urgent que le
plan de réouverture progressive qui a
été discuté avec avec la ministre
s'applique dès demain presque parce que
on est vraiment prêt à accueillir
aujourd'hui des classes dans l'aude en
au théâtre quand on sait qu'on peut en
accueillir aujourd'hui dans des salles
polyvalentes qui sont certainement moins
accueillante en tout cas que nos
théâtres et dans lesquels on peut me
mettre en place toutes les procédures
sanitaires possibles on peut aujourd'hui
sans attendre accueillir deux trois
classes ou des groupes de publics
prioritaires
il faut absolument qu'on puisse
recommencer à créer le lien social qu'on
est capable de faire aussi bien avec les
structures sociales avec lesquels nous
travaillons que les écoles et j'appuie
aussi ce que dit louis tout à l'heure
sur les risques psycho sociaux qui
existent dans nos maisons mais je pense
que c'est la même chose pour les
théâtres privés pour nos collègues des
autres des autres syndicats c'est une
chose qui est sur lesquels il faut
veiller et de pouvoir commencer entre
ouvrir nos maisons va créer beaucoup de
lien aussi avec les salariés merci bien
vous voulez ajouter quelques mots
mathieu morin dit très directe lui très
simple sur sur les collectivités
territoriales qui portent les projets
culturels sur leur territoire qui se
trouve dans une situation d' empêchement
d'exercer leurs compétences et ça nous
fait que trop duré et ce qui n'est pas
sans poser des problèmes importants sur
l'emploi artistique sur l'ensemble de
nos missions sur les territoires les
collectivités territoriales des petites
moyennes collectivités se trouve en
grande difficulté de pouvoir exercer
cette compétence
d'une part elles ne peuvent pas le faire
puisqu'il ya des fermetures
administratives mais en plus au niveau
budgétaire n'étant que peu aidés ou
partiellement aidé par le plan de
relance au cac
il ya une certaine forme d'opacité des
plans de relance concernant les
collectivités territoriales et
particulièrement sur les engagements
auprès des opérateurs artistiques et
culturelles et c'est un point sur lequel
nous avons besoin d'éclaircissements et
de transparence et d'équité territoriale
au niveau national merci alors merci
beaucoup à vous tous pour vos exposé
préliminaire jeu
maintenant donner la parole au
professeur antoine flahault qui est avec
nous donc et directeur de l'institut de
santé globale à l'université de genève
qui un épidémiologiste je crois que tout
le monde connaît et chouette je
souhaiterais qu'ils nous expliquent vous
avez entendu professeur l'ensemble des
acteurs du monde culturel dire alors on
va pas vous intervenez sur la question
économique mais nous dire après tout nos
salles nos lieux de spectacles ne sont
pas tant que ça des lieux à risque et de
toute façon nous sommes conscients de la
situation il existe des protocoles
permettant de réduire au maximum ce
risque qu'en est il des puisque vous
avez une vision qui dépasse celle de la
france une vision interne au sein de ces
questions qu'en est il des données en la
matière est il possible de mener des
activités culturelles sans en minimisant
le risque sanitaire merci de votre
éclairage
merci monsieur merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis donc très honorés d'être invités
votre autre table-ronde je voudrais
c'est tout faire plusieurs coins propos
de ce que vous avez dit de bien sûr
rappelé que l'accès à la culture fait
partie des droits de l'homme donc c'est
sommes en train de discuter mais un
point qui dépasse la question économique
et même la question des éventuels jr
morty sociaux qui permettent à ceux qui
sont couchés dans leur combustion et
dans leur emploi et donc dans l'aurore
revenu à avoir des indemnités ou des
compensations au delà de cela on ne peut
pas compenser une moins atteintes aux
droits de l'homme
un petit peu comme pour le problème de
l'éducation dont on parle souvent
ensuite je voudrais dire des mots
évidemment liminaire que peut-être tout
le monde connaît m'excuserez mais qui
sont nécessaires pour bien comprendre
les raisons de de tout cela et de toutes
ces mesures et la façon dont on pourrait
en effet envisagé de s'en sortir il ya
trois voies principales de transmission
de ce gros navires us qui maintenant
sont connus qui sont les aérosols le
fait que donc nous en respirant
simplement mais bien sûr davantage en
parlant maintenant à peu près 10 fois
dix fois plus en parlant 50 fois plus en
chantant ou en criant nous explorons des
aérosols qui ont différentes volumes
différents diamètres mais dont les plus
légers peuvent rester en l'absence de
d'aération et de ventilation dans l'air
pendant plusieurs heures
ces aérosols pour tous le contaminant
les aérosols dans cette année les
postillons lorsqu'il sent suffisamment
grand de plus de 100 microns à peu près
retombe par la gravité sur le sol ou sur
des surfaces qui peuvent contaminer qui
peuvent être une voie de transmission
même si cette voie de transmission qui
fait qu on nettoie les surfaces qui fait
qu'on se lave les mains même si cette
transmission n'est pas une voie qui a
été beaucoup documenté beaucoup il ya
une très bonne 2e de rapports
scientifiques montrant que cette voie de
transmission mais par précaution on
continue à préconiser bien sûr en tout
cas de lavage des mains probablement un
peu moins
la désinfection des surfaces qui n'est
probablement moins importante qu'on peut
le croire
bien entendu je ne parle pas du partage
d'instruments de musique par exemple ou
de partitions ou de documents qui
pourraient être des sources de
contamination de cette façon là puis une
voix qui trouvait direct lorsque c'est
postillons retombe sur le sol ils
peuvent toucher directement une personne
qui est située à moins de
deux mètres et potentiellement à avec
une distance et un petit peu plus longue
si on prend par exemple des instruments
comme la flûte traversière qui pourrait
expulser à tous certains crient vivre
qui n'ont pas trop de deux labyrinthes
intermédiaire et qui pourrait expulser
des aérosols à de plus grandes distances
autre chose concernant la transmission
qui nous intéresse probablement c'est le
fait que des personnes afin
d'automatiser et surtout d'ailleurs des
personnes qu'on appel pressant
automatique c'est elle qui n'ont pas de
symptômes et ils vont les voir dans les
jours qui vont venir peuvent être des
gens contamine ans expire en actionnant
compliquer la prévention contre cette
maladie parce que ce ne sont pas que les
gens malades qui sont protégés autre
chose c'est qu'il ya besoin d'une dose
infectieuses pour être infecté suffit
pas d'avoir quelques virus dans
l'atmosphère que l'on traverse
il faut que windows est une durée de
l'infectiosité pour pouvoir permettre la
contamination
deuxième point c'était un problème des
rassemblements les rassemblements que
l'on peut avoir
lors de répétitions ou lors de
représentations sont à l'origine d'un
certain nombre de clusters et sont une
des raisons pour lequel le monde du
spectacle assis souffert pendant cette
pandémie
parce que de mesure les interventions de
prévention vise essentiellement à
limiter les rassemblements de personnes
alors y at il eu des clusters dans le
spectacle oui la réponse est oui il ya
une existence de clusters documentée
dans le monde y compris en france
il ya même eu des décès qui ont eu ce
qu'ils ont pu être déplorés soit dans
des choeurs où l'on a senti
rappelez-vous que j'ai dit que on
expulsait 50 fois plus de héros sols
potentiellement contaminants en chantant
il y a eu deux
d ailleurs même des chanteurs solistes
qui on dire l'origine de petites luster
de transmission il ya eu également lors
de ce spectacle de danse parce que la
danse eu probablement entraîne davantage
d'exercices physiques et donc davantage
de risques de transmission le gard où
guillaume japon a été souvent à
l'origine de kloster et puis il ya là
également lors de répétitions ou même de
deux représentations de théâtre ou de
cabaret des créateurs qui ont été vus
aux usa au japon en russie et au canada
[Musique]
en corée du sud notamment également au
québec et en europe
on en a vu aussi donny lia et lé pardon
et aussi en allemagne à berlin en
particulier
donc il ya clairement des des motifs qui
ont pu entraîner la fermeture de ces
établissements de ses représentations
alors les lieux de contamination peuvent
être multiples ils ne sont pas
uniquement dans la salle de
représentation ça peut être les
vestiaires ça pète les lieux de
circulation des personnes
les cafétérias les bars mais aussi on le
sait ça peut être les instruments soit
le partage des instruments ou certains
instruments en particulier instruments à
vent est vraiment pas tous les
instruments à vent pendant les
instruments à vent comme je le disais
tout à l'heure qui ont le moins de 2 de
la virade intermédiaire avant
l'expulsion des aérosols alors des
mesures de prévention il en existe il en
existe et alors je voudrais vous venez
plutôt que de faire simplement la liste
des clubs score je voudrais donner des
exemples positifs est particulièrement
intéressant aujourd'hui il ya des
exemples intéressants en europe ce sont
en particulier l'exemple de l'espagne
qui nous vient tous à l'esprit je pense
l'espagne a laissé la possibilité d'une
culture avec après fort volontarisme
politique d'une culture restée ouverte
pendant toute cette période récente chez
papa du premier confinement mais je
parle depuis le mois de septembre
l'espagne demande une jauge réduite
demandant port de masque obligatoire
absolument à tout le monde bien sûr
s'ouvre aux chanteurs ou sauf aux
joueurs d'instruments à vent demande un
écart entre les spectateurs demande que
les vestiaires et les bars soit fermée a
beaucoup investi sur la ventilation et
l'aération
je voudrais juste un parent de
constatation qui sont presque extrême
mais qui peuvent être quelque part notre
est alors c'est les transports aériens
ou les transports en tgv en france ce
sont les endroits les plus sûrs
quasiment parmi les endroits clos que
nous pouvons connaître ce n'est pas du
tout intuitif on pourrait penser que les
êtres dans une carlingue de 2,1 avions
pendant plusieurs heures dans un long
courrier
ainsi à côté d'une personne infectée qui
tous il ya des symptômes pourraient être
particulièrement à risque
et bien il n'en est presque rien si
jamais rien on il faut pas chercher le
risque zéro sinon on n'arrivera pas à
progresser mais le risque d' absolument
minimale il a été modélisé il a été
montré qu' il ya eu des centaines de
millions de passagers en 2001 même si
aussi le transport aérien a été très
ralentie
il ya eu pas plus de 44 cas recensés
dans le monde entier par la iata donc il
ya extrêmement peu de contamination
parce que le la carlingue d'un avion et
à son air qui est régénérée toutes les 3
à 5 minutes
alors comme il disait sa lettre la
longue or c'est irréalisable dans des
locaux que l'on peut connaître de ça le
spectacle mais en revanche on peut
améliorer grandement la ventilation ce
que les espagnols m'ont fait y compris à
l'opéra real de madrid
il y a donc une ventilation qui permet à
ces héros soient dedans je parlais que
l'on peut comparer à des nuages de de
kabala de fumée de tabac
1 vous savez quand on ne peut plus fumer
désormais dans les salles de spectacles
dans les bars mais qu' on se souvient
probablement un de ces nuages qui
planaient pendant assez longtemps parce
que la ventilation n'est pas suffisante
eh bien vous fumez riez dans un avion
que vous verriez très vite la fumée
disparaître puisque encore une fois
toutes les cinq minutes
mr est totalement régénérer en fait il
n'est pas rémunéré totalement ils
passent parfois par des circuits de de
purification avec des filtres qu'on
appelle des filtres hepa et qui sont une
très grande efficacité contre les aeros
dont nous parlons et en particulier
contre le coronavirus donc il y a des
moyens de purification de l'air
il y a des moyens d'augmentation de la
ventilation qui peuvent être travaillés
dans les salles je pense en particulier
aux petites salles vous parliez des
cabarets les cabarets évoque deux
petites salles chaleureuses cosy
mais vous probablement la ventilation
est pauvre donc si l'on peut améliorer
par des purificateurs d'air c'est
d'ailleurs on n'est pas forcé de
d'améliorer cela part de la régénération
de l'air extérieur qui peut être
compliqué très coûteux mais des
purificateurs d'air pourrait grandement
amélioré la la la qualité de l'air
ambiant
on peut vérifier la qualité de l'air
ambiant de pas lorsqu'il est lorsque la
ventilation est amélioré par des
capteurs de co2 qui ne fonctionnerait
pas antoine
utilisation de purificateurs d'air parce
que le purificateur d'air n'enlève pas
le co2 peut-être pas trop m'étendre sur
le plan technique mais en tout cas si tu
voues ventiler une pièce en ouvrant les
fenêtres ou en utilisant des ventilation
mécanique contrôlée
vous pouvez vérifier par un capteur de
co2 que vous êtes dans des atmosphères
qui sont saines a inspiré qui sent
suffisamment dense il est évidemment
testé cela en présence de deux publics
de personnes donc il y a les moyens de
réduire le risque est qu'ils ont été
tout à fait bien conçu et on peut se
retourner vers l'espagne et leur
expérience pour nous regarder
il ya aussi un traçage qui est mise en
place avec des qr codes avec des
applications importantes rendu
obligatoire ou qui devrait être rendu
obligatoire
peut-être pour permettre de tracer
d'éventuels cluster ok cela ne ferait
que renforcer le fait que les lieux de
spectacles peuvent être tout à fait
sécurisé je veux dire par là que à
barcelone 500 participants à un concert
récemment tout bout très serrés les uns
les autres et tous portant un masque
ils ont tous été testés 0,15 c'était une
expérimentation qui a publié par un à
chercheurs de barcelone donc il est
possible d'avoir des doutes est vraiment
des lieux de spectacles y compris sans
respect de la distance physique car
debout c'est plus difficile
elie soit c'est qu'ils soient sécurisés
à madrid les deux tiers de l'eau bras
1546 sièges donc ça fait quelque chose
comme 1150 siège occupé donc pas un sur
deux et deux tiers les gens qui sont en
famille par exemple d'une employée de
pouvoir s'asseoir à côté
sinon ça n'a pas de sens eh bien on a
montré également 0 k avec des
augmentations alors que l'épidémie
flambé au moment où cela a été fait
c'était au cours du mois de décembre et
de janvier
lynch démis en espagne
d'ailleurs de façon plus substantielle
en france en ce moment voilà on peut
dire aussi que le test des artistes
pourraient être proposées là où il ya
des troupes assez importante pour éviter
que des clusters apparaissent et
menacent la sécurité des des artistes
certains artistes peuvent être à risque
et puis encore une fois on a documenté
des cas de décès ou des cas très graves
chez des artistes donc chez les chiens
les artistes ou chez des choristes donc
il est clair que on peut imaginer un peu
à l'instar de ce que font les sportifs
d'avoir des programmes de testing
bien sûr si les testings doit être
répété ils ne doivent surtout pas aux
trajets parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
inconfortable voire douloureux et qui
pourraient finir par endommager les
cloisons nasales
donc il faut proposer les tests faisable
de ce qu'ils sont
pourquoi pas en reste hier mais qui sont
des tests salivaires sont faciles à
effectuer
on a ce genre de chose en suisse dans
les hôtels du grison où les personnels
donne un peu de salive fréquemment
toutes les semaines au début de leur
travail et sont testés un site très
régulièrement
donc c'est des choses qui sont
envisageables et qui sont ces tueries
bladier je voudrais vous redire pour
répéter parce que je pense que tout le
monde le sait très bien mais finalement
les mesures de prévention elles sont
possibles
on peut être ambitieux pour la culture
on peut créer ouvrir certainement des
spectacles à l'instar de ce que font les
espagnols prédire avec beaucoup de
précaution avec des gestes barrière très
fermement respecter un port de masque
tout à fait respecté par tous les
publics
soudain et de repartir de la salle simon
ne veut pas les respecter
avec une distanciation qui doit être je
dirais original c'est à dire qu'elle
doit permettre encore une fois hamon
à des familles ou des couples de d'une
même famille d'être l'une à côté de
l'autre avec une jauge allégé parce que
bien sûr la densité et la promiscuité
favorise la contamination avec des
durées de spectacles qui peuvent être
réduites
on sait que ce n'est plus la durée
d'exposition est longue et plus le
risque est important et je dirais que la
durée de ce spectacle qui pourrait être
un peu calibré à la qualité de la
ventilation
si vous étiez dans une ventilation de
type aéronautique de type tgv
vous pourriez avoir une durée de
spectacle sans aucune difficulté de plus
de trois heures
mais si vous êtes dans des qualités
probablement modérée enfin moi moins
performante d'aération et de ventilation
alors des spectacles un peu plus court
réduire considérablement le risque ce
qui est dans l'intérêt de tous pour
pouvoir aller continuer la ventilation
je n'y reviens pas je n'ai pas parlé de
vaccination mais bien entendu
la vaccination va concourir à réduire
aussi les risques chez les personnes
âgées qui sont déjà vaccinés
il pourrait y avoir aussi des priorités
pour des secteurs qui ont
particulièrement souffert et qui
pourrait être bénéficier d'une
vaccination que sont les troupes ou les
les orchestres qui serait ainsi protégés
dans leur fonction bien entendu d'autres
secteurs d'activité je pense aux
enseignants seraient sans doute est
visible dans ses priorités mais il faut
peut-être avoir une vision différente
qui concerne que les droits humains dont
je parlais aux tout débuts dans la
priorité maximale qui n'est pas
nécessairement une descente d'âge en âge
de façon linéaire et puis je reviens
vers la notion est l'importance du
travelling de la recherche possible des
contacts et des clusters il faut pouvoir
être en mesure de les rechercher
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on pourra
progresser et
voir se dire que oui c'est sûr
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir dans ce type de
conditions
les spectacles assez rapidement en
france
non c'est notre aventure merci beaucoup
professeur flahault pour cet exposé très
clair moi j'entends les voix intérieures
dans cette salle qui se disent tous mais
qu'attendons nous en fait je vais passer
là si vous pouvez rester avec nous
encore quelques instants parce que je ne
doute pas que vous allez être interrogé
merci beaucoup je passe la parole à
notre rapporteur roger karoutchi
oui merci professeur d'abord parce que
franchement avec dans le climat
anxiogène actuelle avec tout ce qu'on
entend sur toutes les chaînes d'info en
continu une parole claire un peu
organisé un peu structuré avec des
comparaisons internationales et un peu
optimiste sur la suite
qu'est ce que vous voulez par les temps
qui courent ça fait pas de mal non plus
on n'est pas obligé de tout se suicider
donc merci beaucoup pour vos propos mais
en même temps vos propos me ramène si je
puis dire sur le secteur concerné est là
j'aurai deux trois questions à
l'ensemble des acteurs du monde culturel
mais sous le contrôle du professeur
flahault parce que par définition les
dates d'ouverture la progressivité de
l'ouverture les jauges à un moment il
faudra bien que ce soit les les
scientifiques qui le déterminent
première question le président disait
tout à l'heure et plusieurs orateurs ont
dit on a eu en 2020 dz finalement
considérable de la part de l'état ou des
différentes structures publiques ou
parapubliques
mais nous avons tous entendu le ministre
du budget monsieur du soft nous dire que
le quoi qu'il en coûte c'était bien 2020
ça doit se terminer en 2021 et que à
partir de là y aurait probablement une
nouvelle estimation reconsidération des
aides publiques à l'ensemble des
secteurs pas seulement aux secteurs de
culture à l'ensemble des secteurs pour
essayer de réduire
les engagements de l'état et les dettes
qu vide comme on dit aujourd'hui
dans cette perspective comment vous
voyez sur l'ensemble des secteurs
la potentielle réduction des aides
publiques
la possibilité puisque par exemple le
professeur parlé tout à l'heure de
l'espagne enfin en espagne
ils ont aussi dit
le pays n'a n'ayant pas les moyens de
faire du confinement tant pis on ouvre
sous entendu on apporte plus dead des
voyous donc est ce que n'ont pas une
perspective de cet ordre en france ce
serait pas imaginable mais une évolution
de cet ordre apparaît possible dans
votre secteur
deuxième élément au terme de cette
période
on sait pas quand était 2021 peut-être
plus tard puisque quand même on voit mal
l'ensemble des festivals pouvoir se
tenir puisque bon du fait des
programmations de l'organisation les
déjà au mois de mars
ça paraît compromis pour la plupart au
terme de cette période
à votre avis est-ce que le l'ensemble du
secteur
spectacle vivant théâtre concert va être
un secteur qui va devoir qui le souhaite
ou pas d'ailleurs se restructurer est ce
que c'est un secteur où les les la chute
les faillites et difficultés rencontrées
depuis plus d'un an vont entraîner une
restructuration de fêtes de l'ensemble
des secteurs
une disparition potentielle y compris au
delà des aides d'un certain nombre
d'activités de théâtre de compagnie est
ce que vraiment on a un risque fort de
d'appauvrissement en réalité de l'offre
culturelle dans le pays
lié au fait que ben matériel banques
financièrement ça ne tient plus pour un
certain nombre de secteurs nous avons
j'arrêterai là monsieur le président je
vous rassure france-eire d'hommes de
secteurs nous avons vu que certains
mettaient en place des spectacles
numérique si je puis dire ou dans tout
cas
des spectacles 100 spectateurs alors on
voit bien qu'il ya un côté un peu
il faut maintenir l'activité vivre
maintenir les répétitions faire des
spectacles même sain spectateurs on voit
l'opéra de paris on le voit dans un
certain nombre de compagnies est ce que
le développement de ce spectacle
numérique d'abord est-ce que ça a du
sens au niveau purement budgétaire est
ce que c'est un apport qui peut être
important dans la suite de l'avis du
spectacle du théâtre ou bien est-ce que
c'est franchement parce que comme nous
sommes tous plus ou moins confiné où un
couvre-feu
ça maintient un lien mais dérisoire par
rapport à la vie réelle des activités
culturelles et enfin et là j'arrête pour
de bon président sous le couvert du
professeur flahault
est-ce que vous avez un peu d'espoir je
crois que la dernière question est la
plus compliquée mais qui souhaitent
répondre à leur foi la main monsieur
lachenal ont d'abord alesi il
merci en tout cas avant de répondre aux
questions rapidement de monsieur
karoutchi je voudrais remercier le
professeur flahault pour les propos
qu'il a tenus notamment en parlant de
droits humains et d'accès à la culture
et qui sont pour nous évidemment des
droits fondamentaux à quelle heure on
est évidemment très attachés ferait
aussi le remercier sur le sur la part de
d'éléments positifs qu'il a acquis la
donner sur les les capacités à minimiser
les risques dans nos pratiques et je
veux juste faire cette mention à
destination des sénateurs puisque nous
tiendrons bien entendu à leur
disposition ces éléments là nous avons
depuis des mois maintenant engager un
certain nombre de travaux extrêmement
précis avec des organismes scientifiques
technologies les professeurs de médecine
également qui regroupe ce que le
professeur flahault disait on a fait
beaucoup de chemin juste pour rentrer
dans quelques détails mais très rapide
pour dépasser le les mêmes les risques
qu'il a pu dessiner sur les instruments
de musique à la demande et guide des
guides de bonnes pratiques de
désinfection etc
tout ça est maintenant assez assez
sérieux tout ça pour dire également que
ne parlant que nous mon secteur cette
fois ci des opéras et des orchestres le
protocole qu'on a mis en place pour les
orchestres qui ont continué à travailler
pour des captations cause enregistrement
a été extrêmement efficace pendant cette
période puisque en tout cas en france
grâce à ce protocole
aucun kloster n'a eu lieu dans le monde
symphonique dans les autres pièces
depuis mois de septembre
et si effectivement on a pu voir arriver
des cas dans les pratiques vocales on
commence à mieux en déterminer et bien
entendu les raisons elles sont parfois
liés aux environnements comme on en a
parlé
la selle des salles de spectacles
renouvellement d'air est effectivement
permettent aujourd'hui de mettre en
place des procédés nouveaux
je lui dois rappeler maintenant
qu'aujourd'hui les chanteurs acceptent
de chanter masquer ce qui reste d'une
certaine manière la meilleure façon de
se protéger aussi on a fait beaucoup de
progrès là-dessus et on est en train de
faire des mesures je le dis également
pour le professeur flahault sur les
mesures d'aérosols la taille d'été des
aérosols qui sortent des instruments de
tous les instruments les mesures qu'on
peut mettre qui sera à la société
pavillon sera donc là dessus
effectivement on est en train de
continuer à travailler
cela permet de renforcer en tout cas les
protocoles qui sont mis en place et qui
permettent je lui ai dit dans mon propos
liminaire de garantir la sécurité
certes de public mais surtout des gens
qui travaillent sur nos plateaux et
c'est vrai que le spectacle vivant est
un endroit d'interaction physiques
sociales fondamentales et en ce cas
voilà je voulais leur dire sur les
questions tout cas que propose monsieur
46 la question de la baisse des crédits
en 2021 évidemment c'est une c'est une
c'est une donnée très importante pour
nous la reprise se fera de manière
progressive et est forcément dégradée
par rapport aux recettes
on peut avoir donc pour nous il est pas
si vous voulez il et salvatore en tout
cas de pouvoir compter sur les ailes à
la pérennisation des mécanismes qui nous
permettent d'accompagner cette reprise
donc toutes les mécanismes aujourd'hui 2
contres en s'assurant de billetterie de
compensation de coups de plateau c'est
forcément ce sera l'outil de la reprise
qu'ont qui sera qui permettra aux
spectacles vivants de pouvoir reprendre
dans des conditions qui ne seront pas
tout de suite optimale ou pour nous et
effectivement il est pas
alors de considérer que 2021 sera
l'année de revenir sur les
investissements de soutien d'autres
secteurs puisqu'au contraire c'est
vraiment au moment où on est en capacité
de reprendre le la période on a le plus
besoin d'accompagnement l'interprétation
si j'allais dire des dérives que des
faillites
là encore notre secteur on est je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure des opérateurs de
service public donc on ne veut pas
penser qu'on ait un risque de faillite
dans notre secteur on est vraiment les
outils d'une politique publique de la
culture des arts et est à ce titre là on
en appelle des montants dus à la
vigilance de toutes les personnes qui
composent des organes de gouvernance et
qui participe au financement des
structures qu'on représente que ce soit
l'état les collectivités territoriales
en premier lieu bien évidemment et puis
pour en finir sur la question du
numérique
voilà tout est dans la question c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui ce sont des
activités qui sont clairement des
activités de substitution d'un point de
vue artistique et d'un point de vue
culturel à rien ne remplacera la
rencontre physique de des spectateurs du
public et des artistes c'est évident il
faut à tout prix le défendre on est des
entreprises de spectacle vivant et le
spectacle vivant à cela a quelque chose
de magique dès lors que le rideau se
lève tout peut se passer ces rapports
directs aux artistes à leur expression
politique est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument nous conserver donc
aujourd'hui effectivement les moyens de
diffusion alternatif que le numérique
permet à permis effectivement à des
équipes de rester au travail des
artistes de continuer à de faire leur
métier mais c'est une forme de pis-aller
dont aujourd'hui on absolument pas
construire de modèle économique pérenne
pour l'avenir qu'il y avait une question
et sur la viabilité économique
nous savons que les expériences qui sont
menées se font grâce aux aides
mobilisées par le centre national de la
musique le centre national du cinéma
mais est-ce qu'il y aura une réalité
économique à cela il est trop tôt pour
le dire
il a fallu beaucoup de temps à la
musique pour s'adapter à un numérique
aux plaques pour passer d'un état de
pillages permanent si je peux dire à une
période à des systèmes de diffusion plus
responsables avec les plateformes de
streaming payant
on en est encore
cette étape de maturité je pense pour le
spectacle vivant et ce sont des
questions qui sont plutôt liées à
l'avenir merkel qui ne sont pas des
éléments de réponse aujourd'hui à la
crise
pour pouvoir en sortir très
immédiatement voilà allez-y monsieur
bande à baader c'est ça je représente le
syndicat du spectacle vivant privé
merci nous donner la parole et merci de
le faire sur rendez vous trois petites
choses j'essaie d'être bref et la
première chose c'est qu'il faut pas se
méprendre sur le déconfinement de la
culture vous avez beau des confiné des
salles de spectacles de rue mode est
confiné des festivals si nos spectateurs
ne sont pas entre guillemets des
comprimés et donc pas apte ou enclins à
acheter des billets de spectacles notre
écosystème privé va mourir ou est en
danger ça c'est extrêmement important ce
n'est pas l'alpha et l'oméga de des
confiner les lieux de spectacles en tout
cas pour nous la deuxième chose c'est
que si le programme est aussi professeur
flahault d'être là mais on a un absent
de sa discussion qui est le vaccin
on a la chance d'avoir un président de
la république qui vient nous annoncer
une promesse très forte de dire que à la
fin de l'été l'ensemble de la population
française serait vacciné
de deux choses l'une silas l'ensemble de
la population française est vaccinée à
la fin de l'été ça nous donne un
rétroplanning très clairs de reprise de
nos activités avec peu de contraintes
sanitaires qui s'exerceront à partir du
20 septembre ou début octobre à partir
du moment où on se base sur le la fin de
l'été au 21 septembre
la troisième chose c'est sur les aides
les aides
vous avez une temporalité des aides qui
est complètement différente et
disparates et un monde donné il faudra
se poser la cohérence des aides sur le
secteur culturel et l'activité
culturelle
je vous donne un exemple vous avez des
aides sectorielles et des aides
transversale sur les aides sectorielles
on a une temporalité qui sort de
l'immédiateté de le du du besoin
vous avez des dossiers de consultation
vous avez des comités de consultation et
au terme des consultations vous avez de
la trésorerie qui tombe dans les
entreprises spectacle vivant privé
c'est un ton l'on sait le temps d'étude
c'est le temps administratif dans le
fonds de solidarité
annoncé par bruno le maire vous avez une
efficacité et une temporalité qui est
extrêmement bonnes
et vertueuse pour les entreprises les
entreprises elles font solidarité vous
est séquencée sur des mois vous avez
temps de charge au mois on sait que les
entreprises ont besoin de compenser des
charges payer des salaires payer leur
loyer payé des frais divers et variés
qui composent les frais de structure
d'entreprise et le fonds de solidarité
vient récompenser au maximum de ses
possibilités au mois aux mois sans
décalage de temporalité donc avec le
fonds sectoriel et avec le front
transversale on est une complémentarité
des aides mais une des synchronicité de
son efficacité
je vous donne un exemple font
transversale exceptionnelle qui a été
allouée au spectacle vivant privé qui
devait être de 200 millions ramené à 115
millions d'euros
je préfère le rappeler est aujourd'hui
un fonds qui est allouée au titre des
pertes des entreprises de 2020 et sera
très vraisemblablement versé aux entre à
ces mêmes entreprises en juin voire en
septembre 2021
on oublie donc qu'à partir du 1er
janvier 2021
la crise joue à plein pour ces mêmes
entreprises sans aucune sans aucun
comblement ou allocation pour combler ce
même déficit qui se recrutent à partir
de janvier on comble déjà 20 en
septembre
mais on ne se préoccupe même pas du
déficit qui est creusée sur 2021 donc le
fonds de solidarité et c'est pour ça
qu'on nous demande et qu'on vous demande
d'appuyer le fait que le secteur est ce
un essaim bis soit pleinement actes et
dont le fonds de solidarité pour que les
entreprises secteur culturel puisse y
avoir droit
parce que cet écart de temporalité
risque d'être fatal aux entreprises pour
en terminer notre fonds nous l'avons
séquences et c'est le produit qui est à
la manoeuvre et à l'écriture en
présentant leurs ex
c'est à dire que nous demandons un
dédommagement sur les pertes réelles des
entreprises
pas tant sur les charges sur les pertes
réelles toute compensation fait des
aides publiques qui auront été données
nous il nous semble que c'est un système
juste et vertueux qui devrait
s'harmoniser
merci madame gentil l'homme oui oui par
rapport à la question sur sur les
mesures de soutien dès lors qu'on ne
connaît pas les conditions de la reprise
c'est compliqué de dire qu'on voit là
les mesures de soutien pourraient
pourrait s'arrêter aujourd'hui si on
reprend avec une jauge de 50% de 60% ou
de 40% bien évidemment pour les secteurs
du specta lyon privée et qu'il ne sera
nécessaire d'être accompagné au regard
de conditions financières qui pourraient
ne pas être les mêmes en fonction de la
façon dont on pourra reprendre de la
même façon comme je voulais indiqué tout
à l'heure pour le théâtre dès lors qu'il
ya des mesures de couvre-feu qui sont
maintenus sa combine aussi une partie de
nos activités et notamment les multis
programmation pour les petites salles
qui sont absolument essentielles pour
leur économie
donc voilà c'est c'est compliqué de vous
dire aujourd'hui on va pouvoir se passer
des aides et quand on pourra se passer
des aides des leurs comptes ne connais
absolument pas les conditions de la
reprise et à savoir aussi comme le
rappelait aurélien d'un verre si le
public sera aussi au rendez vous d'une
reprise dès que les salles sont en
capacité de rouvrir par rapport à votre
question sur sur les offres qu'ils
soient des captations moi je voudrais
rappeler qu'il ya des captations dans le
théâtre depuis depuis longtemps mais
c'est une activité qui est excessivement
marginal ça n'est pas la même chose que
le spectacle vivant bien évidemment et
et que là on parle de spectacle vivant
et qui dit spectacle vivant c'est un
rapport entre une scène et une salle
c'est c'est un partage d'émotions entre
des comédiens qui transmettent à une
salle plus ou moins pleines et
d'ailleurs ça fait partie aussi de ne
pas la dot de la l'expérience qu'on peut
avoir dans une salle pleine et je
voudrais surtout insisté sur un autre
point
on apparaît aussi bien social et la
grande
treize psychologique dans laquelle se
trouve ça une partie de nos concitoyens
aller au spectacle partager un moment
d'émotion dans une salle ça contribue
aussi à créer du lien social et c'est
pas du tout la même chose que d'être
tout seul face à un écran et je crois
que c'est absolument dramatique de
penser qu' on pourrait substituer du
vrai spectacle vivant dans une salle
avec un partage d'émotions à un filtre
d'un écran tout seul chez soi
merci merci un peu peut-être professeur
flahault voulait réagir à
l'interpellation de monsieur ben d'air
sur est alors quand le vaccin qu'on va
atteindre un taux de vaccination
important de la population de toute
façon on peut reprendre une vie normale
oui je suis partant cet espoir
je pense que c'est même l'objectif que
deux nominations sont de blois
rapidement reprendre une vie normale
on va voir on a un une sorte de
laboratoire vivant qui est constituée
par israël aujourd'hui puisque d'ores et
déjà plutôt important d'occasions
adultes et maxime et et que l'on va voir
un petit peu comment comment rené la vie
elle est la vie sociale et la vie
économique dans ce pays
on va aussi avoir un petit peu plus
lentement peut-être mais l'expérience
britannique
monsieur en la matière donc c'est vrai
il reste un seul point pour l'instant
encore un petit peu incertain qui est
l'absence de transmission ou autres cas
la réduction de la transmission du virus
le grâce à la vaccination c'est
l'accession empêche d'être malade
empêche des formes sévères de la maladie
ce qui est très heureux parce qu'il n'
empêche de façon extrêmement efficace le
probablement pratiquement à 100% mais en
revanche on ne sait pas
mesure il réduit la transmission et donc
le risque de transmission à l'autre
parce que certains vaccins ne réduisent
pas nouveau la transmission mais sont
extrêmement efficaces sur les maladies
sévères il ya de bons arguments
aujourd'hui pour commencer à penser
qu'il va y avoir aussi de très bonnes
nouvelles de ce côté là donc mais des
études qui prennent un peu plus de temps
et colin pour le moment on a juste
l'espoir que également la transmission
intra sera fortement réduite
et si c'est le cas en effet on aura une
vie beaucoup plus normal
une fois vacciner sous réserve bien
entendu qu on va encore avoir d'autres
mutants ou variant qui viennent obérer
l'efficacité de cette vaccination ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui bien merci
professeur donc ce qui ce qui ne nous
exonère pas tout au contraire de
travailler à une reprise plus rapide à
certaines conditions votre exposé était
très clair je vais passer la parole à
notre second à porter le jean michel
arnaud et puis ensuite aux collègues qui
souhaiteront poser des questions une
sueur président merci merci à tous les
intervenants pour la richesse de leurs
analyses et est également l'expression
des conditions difficiles dans lequel se
trouve la filière culturelle
juste une observation je serai très bref
pour laisser la parole aux autres
personnes qui souhaitent s'exprimer
je crois que le travail la mission est
effectivement de capter
les difficultés liées à la nature du
virus comme l'a dit le professeur
flahault cat également les difficultés à
court terme qui sont les vôtres je crois
pour les uns exprimé de manière
puissante avec cet espoir puisque le
présent 46 a évoqué le terme d' espoir
de pouvoir travailler puisque vous
demander finalement comme tous les
professionnels seulement d'exercer votre
métier de pouvoir retrouver une vie
normale et notamment une vie économique
normale
ceci étant dit une un des objectifs
parmi d'autres de la mission est de se
préparer aussi à moyen long terme à la
réitération finalement une situation
telle que nous la vivons et il me semble
important en particulier sur les
suggestions les recommandations certaine
manière du professeur flahault de voir
comment à moyen et long terme
on en rit envisage et à quel coût
d'adaptation une restructuration
finalement des salles des vieux des
lieux de vie culturelle dans notre pays
et même si on est aujourd'hui encore la
tête dans le guidon
je crois qu'il faudra effectivement voir
de quelle manière on se prépare à
l'avenir et qu'elle n'aime pas cela peut
avoir sur votre organisation vous avez
évoqué et c'est vrai dans beaucoup de
métiers
finalement la révélation de la diversité
juridique aussi des supports de vos
activités donc une rente tremblements un
travail aussi peut-être pas
d'harmonisation dans tous les cas de
leurs projections sur sur ses modes
juridique déjà d'organisation aux
activités de leur financement
je vois bien et c'est un classique
entre les scènes publiques et et les
activités privées des nuances pour dire
les choses de manière douce et
convenable dans une institution comme
celle du sénat et puis voir de quelle
manière effectivement sur sur les lieux
de vie quels sont les éléments sur
lesquels il va falloir au long cours
travailler avec vous avec évidemment
l'état avec quels moyens financiers pour
permettre aussi de préparer cette mue
absolument indispensable pour qu'on ne
se retrouve pas avec un autre virus avec
une autre situation de plus en plus
imprévisibles les unes après les autres
et que le réchauffement climatique en
particulier à des situations qui serait
de nouveau très difficile est derrière
les aides à court terme de l'état qui
vous permettent de survivre en espérant
le retour du public vous l'avez dit
également
j'aimerais aussi qu'on est à la
réflexion monsieur comment convaincre le
public au delà des situations
techniques sur lesquels vous travaillez
comme en génère également une vision
culturelle pour que le public reste avec
nous et et envie de revenir dans vos
lieux de vie et dans vos lieux
d'expression culturelle évolué
économique merci alors j'ai passé
directement la parole aux collègues qui
se sont inscrits et vous pourrez après
répondre à l'ensemble des interventions
en commençant par sylvie robert merci
monsieur le président et bonjour à
toutes et à tous en vous entendant je me
disais que le rapport que j'avais commis
sur la situation de la culture après le
premier confinement étaient pour
certaines préconisations encore
d'actualité et notamment la question de
la visibilité du cadre que vous avez
bien rappeler pour autant on n'est pas
dans la même période et heureusement
n'est peut-être au bout du tunnel
il ya eu des expériences monsieur
flahaut l'a évoqué il ya aussi vos
travaux parce que la question du
protocole et je dis tout le temps que
vous êtes vraiment des professionnels
responsables et que vous travaillez
beaucoup sur ces réouvertures et donc
tout ça doit nous permettre forcément
d'envisager
d'être un petit peu plus optimistes
qu'aujourd'hui pour autant j'aurais
quelques questions et notamment sur les
aides oui la différence est aussi les
impact psychologique sur la population
on en parlait pas à l'époque on a
beaucoup parlé impacts économiques
sociaux
mais là la question psychologique est
vraiment importante et je crois qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on l'a souligne alors
je voudrais vous poser quelques
questions je suis un peu étonné la façon
dont le plan de relance que nous avons
voté chers collègues assez conséquent
pour la culture se met en oeuvre
aujourd'hui dans les territoires je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez mais
j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
d'autant que moi je l'aurais plutôt
appelé plan de reprise parce que la
relance va être autre chose et je crois
que justement il va falloir que on se
projette sur d'autres modalités
d'accompagnement et notamment dans un
contexte où j'aimerais aussi avoir votre
sentiment
ou beaucoup d'artistes sont fragilisés
où il ya eu beaucoup de créations qui
ont été reportés voire annulés des
projets voilà qui restent dans les
cartons
ou quand même les théâtres un certain
nombre d'équipements ont été ouverts
pour de nouvelles créations
dites moi comment vont pouvoir se bâtir
les prochaines saisons ça c est
économiquement derrière on le voit bien
si en plus on s'apprête à se dire qu' il
n'y aura peut-être pas de nouveaux plans
de relance
je dis bien relancé non pas reprises ça
peut être un peu difficile
la question des festivals est-ce que
vous pensez que l'est qui a été annoncé
par la ministre le fonds de soutien des
festivals est suffisant et je suis un
peu étonné de ne pas entendre et
monsieur flahaut pourtant là bien évoqué
en tout cas de réflexion autour d'un
fonds de soutien d'équipement
d'investissement pour que les salles et
vous l'avez vraiment bien dit puissent
être conformes en tous cas en conformité
avec les protocoles là aussi j'entends
peu de choses mais y aura les
collectivités territoriales faucons
dragons soit vigilant parce que ça
pourra aussi être un sujet avec les
collectivités territoriales
je voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez du
pass sanitaires alors je sais pas si
c'est comme ça qu'on doit l'appeler mais
j'en ai j'ai entendu présent de la
république en parler comme ça mais ce
flahaut l'a bien dit un coup à leur code
traçage et c est ce que ce sont déjà que
ce soit dans le secteur privé que seul
un secteur peu subventionné
est-ce que c'est déjà quelque chose que
vous avez analysé et enfin pour aller
être brève
monsieur flahaut vous avez donc beaucoup
parlé des des situations des salles il
s'avère que l'été il ya beaucoup de
festivals en plein air on est quand même
en plein air et c'est vrai que même si
on se dit qu'on sera dans une situation
quand même un peu plus favorable
est-ce que les risques que vous avez
évoquées sont aussi importants lorsqu'on
est en jauge de boue ou même comme vous
l'avez dit dans une salle on ne peut pas
avoir de distanciation
mais on est vraiment en plein air est-ce
que là il ya vraiment un risque pour
ben vous voyez à quoi je pense c'est à
dire les festivals de cet été est
singulièrement est ce que la question de
la jauge est un indicateur qui est un
bon indicateur
voilà merci evelyne renault garabédian
moi je voudrais vous poser deux
questions et et faire un constat je
connais pas du tout le secteur de la
culture
moi je suis du secteur du tourisme et
l'hôtellerie donc j'essaie de faire le
parallèle entre tout ce que vous avez
dit que je vous remercie pas c'était
particulièrement intéressant est ce que
nous on vit dans le secteur du tourisme
et de l'hôtellerie de la restauration
tout d'abord si j'écoute le professeur
flahault
il nous a dit que dans les avions et
dans des compagnies aériennes il y avait
énormément de gens qu'ils utilisaient et
qu'il n'y avait pas eu beaucoup de cas
de contamination à cause de la
purification de l'air si j'ai bien
compris
excusez moi je ne suis pas une
technicienne
pourquoi dans les salles de cinéma où il
n'y a pas ce risque de transpiration où
il n'y a pas ce risque d'éclabousser
mans dans la bouche
pourquoi est ce qu'on demande pas aux
propriétaires des salles de cinéma
d'envisager de modifier et de purifier
l'air pour que si deux personnes sont
assises l'une à côté de l'autre ou avec
un siège il n'y a pas de risque
effectivement de contamination donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on essaie pas
techniquement de voir s'il est possible
pour les salles de cinéma d'envisager
cette possibilité
deuxièmement une question que je voulais
vous poser économiquement pour que une
salle de spectacle soit viable
économiquement
il faut que la jauge du nombre de
personnes qui ont accueilli c'est
combien de personnes faut que ce soit
1000 fourchette 2000 faut que ce soit 6%
du pourcentage de la salle une simple
qui reçoit dix mille spectateurs
il faut que sur les dix mille
spectateurs il est obligatoirement pour
que ce soit économiquement viables la
moitié le car pour avoir une idée
et puis les compagnies d'assurance est
ce que vous vous avez eu des couvertures
dans les compagnies nation parce
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de spectacles
ont été annulés
et des sommes ont dieu est encaissée par
les salles de spectacle et part des
organisateurs et spectacles qui ne
peuvent pas être servies à la clientèle
comment est-ce que ces sommes-là sont
traités est ce que les compagnies
d'assurance vont rembourser
est ce que les salles vous rembourser
les sommes qu'ils ont encaissées parce
que je pense pas qu'ils ont été capables
de rembourser eux-mêmes les sommes
qu'ils avaient déjà encaissé
donc j'aimerais savoir comment ça se
passe avec les compagnies d'assurance et
de voir c'est une possibilité ou pas
dans les polices d'assurance de
d'envisager ces couvertures et s'il y en
avait est ce que dans les
renouvellements des polices d'assurance
parce que ça fait un an que nous sommes
dans une situation de épidémique
les polices d'assurance ont été
renouvelés par les compagnies
d'assurances puisque au bout d'un an
soit elle réside hills où elle continue
est ce que les
les polices d'assurance ont été alors
pourquoi je vous pose cette question
excusez moi c'est parce que nous en
matière hôtelière les compagnies
d'assurances n'étaient pas claires elles
ont résilié toutes les polices
d'assurance au 31 décembre
alors elles ont annoncé évidemment
qu'elle maintenait les garanties mais le
montant des primes n'étaient pas élevées
mais les garanties sont plus du tout les
mêmes
elles ont diminué de plus de la moitié
alors comment ça se passe dans votre
secteur d'activité
merci de vos réponses alors personne de
mes collègues néant demandé la parole je
vais vous passez donc
à vous la parole pour des réponses dans
un temps qui est extrêmement contraint
vous l'avez deviné d'autant qu'il ya un
nombre de questions et de remarques
importantes qui est impressionnant de la
partie civile robert et jean reno
garabédian dois bien le dire le prodiss
vous commencez à lévis bonjour à tous
oui effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
questions donc je vais essayer d'être
est assez binaire
même si certaines questions un appel à
plus de jeu vers la première question je
monsieur le rapporteur sur le futur
voulait ma mort je suis président d'un
pendant 3 ans voulaient que je sois
président pour les quinze années qui
viennent ça me
ça ne sécurise pas mais en tout cas pour
la crise aujourd'hui il ya quelque chose
qui est extrêmement importante
on eu cette conviction le pass sanitaire
la vaccination pour nous c'est le début
de la lumière au bout du tunnel
non je parle vraiment d'un point de vue
spectacle vivant privé avec des modèles
économiques extrêmement compliqué pour
répondre très vite à votre question nous
si nous n'avons pas 80 voire 90 % de
taux de remplissage
nous sommes à août donc de redémarrer à
50% ce n'est pas possible pour nous ou
alors on se dit que c'est une phase de
transition pour l'expérimentation
sanitaire mais économiquement sa
produira bien entendu de la casse donc
pour nous tant que nous sommes pas 80 ou
90 % des capacités
quelle qu'elle soit on est foutus
enfin foutu julie on est on est dans un
désastre 2
donc le pass alors je comprends bien que
le pass sanitaire et que le la
vaccination pose des problèmes d'éthique
de liberté je le conçois surtout dans un
pays tel que le nôtre ça ne pose
beaucoup moins
le problème dans les pays nordiques est
ce que c'est le fait qu'ils soient
luthérien ou calvini ce je n'en sais
rien mais en tout cas c'est une réalité
dans les pays du nord
cette question n'est pas tout à fait
voilà on la conçoit pas de la même façon
que chez nous le pragmatisme voudrait me
faire dire que c'est notre seule
solution le la vaccination et le pass
sanitaires maintenant je comprends que
ça soulève des questions sociétales
malheureusement il sera un
malheureusement ou heureusement ça sera
imposée vous parliez du du de l'aérien
par exemple aérien si vous allez voyager
dans le monde
dans les années qui viennent il y aura
une obligation de présenter certainement
carnet vaccinal on l'appelle passeport
vaccinale c'est peut-être un petit peu
trop liberty si je ne sais pas comment
le dire mais en tout cas incarner vexe
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se fait quand
vous allez en afrique dans la plupart
des pays alors donc je pense qu'on va y
aller petit à petit vers sète que ça
vous plaise que ça ne plaise pas pour
nous c'est un espoir
il faut que je remette mon masque
cependant inscrit
voilà je crois alors je vais tellement
de questions sur sur la période de la
territorialité la façon dont les aides
arrivent là aussi il y à petit il ya les
aides nationales qui viennent un petit
peu avec des temporalités différentes
nous spectacle vivant privé
on nous a quelquefois dit pourquoi vous
seriez éligibles à ce fonds puisque vous
avez un fonds sectoriels de sauvegarde
en fait ce qui est très important c'est
que nous nous sommes des entrepreneurs
est derrière ce mot entrepreneur qui a
une certaine faculté à comprendre ce
qu'est le risque et le risque c'est
notre métier depuis le début quand on
met de l'argent sur la production d'un
spectacle on n'est absolument pas sûr de
recouper le les sommes investies et bien
c'est un risque qu'on prend volontiers
sinon nous ne serions pas entrepreneur
l'entreprise
l'entrepreneur c'est celui qui
entreprend et qui gère cette part
risques et profits espérés mois
je dirais que quand nous avons demandé
ce fonds de sauvegarde qui a été obtenu
en août 2000
20 20 quand après de longs mois après
l'étude on m'a dit qu'à a parlé c'est à
dire on a fait des études d'impact pas
un parent
higuain dont cabinet indépendant et
quand c'est arrivé et nous avons bien
entendu fondée aux aides et qu'il
fallait aller chercher sur ce rapport
qui se proposait de d'indemniser d'une
façon virtuose vertueuse pardon tous les
acteurs de notre site de notre
écosystème et d'aller bien entendu
défendre l'indépendance les petits les
petits acteurs qui seraient les mieux
indemnisés et les très gros qui sont des
acteurs souvent avec un actionnariat
très fort
[Musique]